Behind the look of every Tesla
is the vision of one man.
And no, it’s not Elon Musk.
You may have become aware of Franz von Holzhausen
when he smashed a Cybertruck window by accident.
Oh my f***ing God. Well,
maybe that was a little too hard.
And then the same thing happened again.
Awww man!
Softening the truck with a sledgehammer
beforehand certainly didn’t help!
Franz von Holzhausen is the lead designer at
Tesla, arguably one of the best in the world.
Anyway, welcome Franz.
Awesome to have you guys.
Designing is in his blood.
His father was an industrial
designer in Connecticut
and Franz followed in his footsteps, studying
industrial design at Syracuse University.
However, while working for his dad,
an intern mentioned a design school
out in LA which piqued his interest, so he
left Syracuse two years into his studies
and enrolled at the ArtCenter College
of Design. He also spent time at its
sister campus in Switzerland which
exposed him to European influences.
He wanted a career that
focused on his love of cars.
He once said it was important for him
to design products that were not just
beautiful but useful to people.
In 1992, he joined Volkswagen straight out
of school to work on a top-secret project:
redesigning the Beetle.
The Concept One is all but forgotten today.
But in 1994, people went crazy for
the new take on the retro design.
It looked a lot simpler than
the Beetle of the sixties.
Von Holzhausen had an eye for
minimalism early in his career.
He realized the look of a car could
change the way people felt about a brand.
The new Beetle brought back a sense of nostalgia
and helped reinvigorate a company in decline.
Soon, other brands decided to go
retro: Chrysler with the PT Cruiser,
the Mini Cooper, and Ford with
the fifth-generation Mustang.
After nearly eight years at VW, he
moved to General Motors…where he
led the design for Pontiac’s
Solstice and the Saturn Sky.
Although they didn’t do well sales-wise, they were
seen as really “cool” roadsters. Pure and fun.
But as it turned out, working at a big
car company with a huge design team
wasn’t his thing…as he couldn’t make the
kind of impact he knew he could make.
Von Holzhausen put it this way during an interview
with Ashlee Vance for his biography on Elon Musk:
“I knew I didn’t want to die there.”
After five years at GM, Mazda came calling.
Von Holzhausen produced concept
cars that reinvigorated Mazda.
Or, as von Holzhausen put it to Vance:
Zoom zoom.
Three years later, in 2008,
he left Mazda for Tesla.
A friend had told von Holzhausen that
Tesla was looking for a chief designer.
He reached out to Musk’s assistant
Mary Beth Brown and eventually met
Musk for an interview at SpaceX headquarters.
Musk liked what he saw and sold it as
an opportunity to leave a cushy job
to work for a company that could
potentially shape the future.
They took a drive in the Roadster and
Von Holzhausen thought to himself,
as he recalled to Vance:
He said most of his colleagues thought
he was crazy for joining Tesla.
It was super risky. Very few car
start-ups succeed. Back then,
Musk only gave Tesla a 10% shot of surviving.
Musk hired von Holzhausen
specifically to design the Model S.
He didn’t have much to work with -
just a few sketches and a clay model.
He knew the Model S would need to be ICONIC. This
would be the foundation for the entire Tesla line.
He once said it needed to attract
people like a moth to a flame.
He designed the Model S in a
corner of SpaceX’s factory and
reportedly worked on the prototype in
a tent to keep away from prying eyes.
Musk handed over the creative reins
to von Holzhausen but he did stipulate
that the Model S needed to be cool
like an Aston Martin or a Porsche.
It needed to have a touchscreen as
iPhone technology was now all the rage
and Musk knew it would soon be commonplace.
But a touchscreen had never before been installed
in a car. And the iPad was still years away.
Musk and von Holzhausen also drove the
engineers crazy when they insisted on a smooth,
clean look for the door handles - as in, they only
stuck out when the door had to be opened.
Despite the reluctance of the engineers, in
the end, they got their way!
Musk also insisted on making the
body of the Model S out of aluminum rather than
steel to compensate for the heavy battery pack.
Except car companies in North America had no
experience producing body panels made of aluminum.
Aluminum is prone to cracking
when it’s bent. It can also
develop lines that can make it
difficult to hide with paint.
But the Tesla engineers got it done.
The year von Holzhausen joined Tesla, in 2008,
the company struggled financially. In fact,
Tesla nearly went bankrupt on Christmas Eve.
That’s why von Holzhausen desperately
wanted to show the Model S to the world,
to get people excited about
what the company had to offer.
In March 2009, just six months after
von Holzhausen joined the team,
Tesla unveiled a grey Model S at a media event.
The media fawned over it.
Wired magazine described it as
a “stunningly beautiful car”
Few knew it at the time, but the Model S was
far from being ready for the road. Unbeknownst
to reporters, the car had the base structure
of a Mercedes CLS according to Ashlee Vance.
The Mercedes CLS was the foundation
they used when working on the S.
Despite the work that still had to be done, Tesla
achieved its goal of convincing people that it
could make beautiful electric cars…and compete
with the big players like Audi, Mercedes, and BMW.
The Model S was a commercial success and proved
to doubters there was indeed a market for EVs.
The original Model S was delivered in
2012 but it doesn’t show its age even
ten years later. It still
looks pretty modern today.
The newer version of the S no longer includes the
nose cone at the front, amongst other changes.
That was decorative, not functional, so they
took it away - simplifying the look even more.
Von Holzhausen’s motto from the start
has been simplicity without excess.
Which has been baked into every
Tesla since - including the Model 3,
and will be an integral
part of every Tesla to come.
If you dream of building incredible products
and would like to excel in math and science in
order to do so, you can join the 11 million
people who have signed up for Brilliant.
Brilliant is an amazing tool for
learning STEM in a fun, hands-on way.
Just as the Tesla team is using neural networks
to achieve self-driving, you can delve into the
world of neural networks through Brilliant’s
Introduction to Neural Networks course.
To help push your math skills to the next level,
you can learn problem-solving techniques with
their Mathematical Fundamentals course.
Or learn the key ideas of computer science
with their Computer Science Fundamentals
course - and no coding is required.
Brilliant is great whether you’re in high school,
university, or already in the workforce. There are
no tests and if you’re ever stuck - you can click
on “view explanation” to see where you went wrong.
To get started for FREE, head to the custom link
in my description: brilliant.org/newsthink. And
the first 200 of you to sign up with my link will
get 20% off Brilliant’s Premium subscription which
gives you unlimited access to all the courses.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.